That’s game!
It’s win by two!
Not here, it’s not.
Hey, they letting yoga instructors
in the gym now.
Ball!
I just noticed you’re not getting
enough legs under your
shot. Are you dehydrated?
$100 you can’t make more shots.
Let’s just do $300.
It’s not my dad’s money.
We ain’t never gonna get our reparations that way, bruh.
So, I prefer Venmo or Zelle,
but you seem like
a Cash App guy, so...
♫ Ladies and gentlemen ♫
♫ C5 (oh) ♫
You think you’re slick, huh?
Showing up to courts dressed like a
dumbass, acting like you can’t hoop.
You assumed I couldn’t hoop
because I’m white, which
is incredibly outdated.
No, I assumed you couldn’t hoop
because you were dressed like
a white girl at Whole Foods.
♫ Where the love go? ♫
It’s really hard to plan for the future
when we’re always worried about
money because you’re out here
living in a fantasy.
My 30 day detox program.
You want a free sample?
Nah, I ain’t drinking no booboo juice.
Babe, it’s almost the first.
I’m gonna go tomorrow. I forgot.
Why don’t you just go now?
It’ll be fine! Say don't worry, Mommy!
Don’t worry, Mommy!
Every hooper I know is entering that
big ass tournament where the
winner gets $500,000.
I just need somebody who can play
so I could make some money.
You’re joking, right?
$500,000.
For one day of hoop.
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♫
♫ You're a roughneck ♫
We can hustle a few games together
to get the money for the entry fee.
I’ll find some marks.
Those short shorts look incredible on you.
Throw them off their game.
You have an OnlyFans?
And we’ll clean up.
You gonna wear that trash bag?
You gonna wear that fake ass
Richard Simmons outfit?
♫ Oh! Get the F though ♫
♫ I don't bluff, bro ♫
I bet y’all got more in common
than meets the eye.
Release for me. Release for me.
- That’s debatable.
-  I doubt that.
♫ That's enough jokes ♫
♫ Then the sun die ♫
Don’t spend any of the money
until we can cover the fee.
I should be saying that to you.
I'm good with money.
So am I.
Me too.
Word.
Word, bruh.
♫ If she's iffy, there the drugs go ♫
Okay, I see you.
♫ Double-cup toast ♫
♫ I got a duffle full of hundos ♫
♫ There the love go ♫
Buckets.
What?
Just wanted to see if you had
superhuman hearing ‘cause of your...
‘Cause of my what?!
Whoa, he’s got a knife!
They’re gonna kill him in the parking lot.
I’m out of here. He got a flamethrower.
Flamethrower? What is this, Mad Max?
♫ 5, 4, 3, 2, I let one go ♫
♫ Pow, get the F though
I don't bluff, bro ♫
I don’t know how much you talking trash played into that,
but good work.
Thank you. You could talk
way more trash out there.
You have so much material
I can’t even touch.
Like what?
Never mind.
No! Tell us.
♫ Where the love go ♫